joining us now is country
singer-songwriter and overall really
awesome person
Ernest what's going on good how are you
doing it's good to see you I'm so stoked
for you to be back in Los Angeles for
such a fun week closing out the
dangerous tour with your buddy Morgan
Wallen yes ma'am how has that been it's
been a dream uh just to get to go around
the country with your best friends yeah
yeah so it's unlike anything I could
have thought of because that's a thing
is it's also hearty as well and you
three are quite the trio
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is it like behind the scenes when
you guys are off stage and just soaking
up the moments together and I think it's
cool because we're all each other's
biggest cheerleader you know it's like
in such a dog eat dog world it's kind of
cool to have you know guys that are
competing for spots on the charts at the
same time rooting rooting for those guys
and writing each other songs and all
that it's cool so awesome is that you
guys are literally rising at the same
time and the records that y'all are
breaking and the number ones that you're
scoring Like It's gotta be the coolest
feeling in the world it is and it's
um I'd say it's a testament to just the
grind we've all put in for the last 10
years they say it's a 10-year town and
it really is but her name was
[Music]
and next up you'll be going out on your
own tour sucker for small towns tour
that's right can fans expect with that
oh like an hour and a half of just a
good time good music a lot of steel
guitar playing
I'm taking Jake Worthington out with me
some too and he's about as starch Gene
country music as it gets oh yeah I love
it so when you say like a good time for
those who may have not seen an Earnest
show yet what does that good time entail
good time entails uh some real country
music real songwriting real instruments
and a party environment and I'll
probably be playing some songs that I've
written for some of my friends as well
love it yeah
[Music]
now will your family hit the road with
you too when they can okay we're working
on our bus situation and having rhyming
out with my band is a little bit of a
headache you posted the sweetest photo
of Ryman playing the guitar you
captioned it natural I mean hey it looks
like he may be following a dad's
footsteps yeah we'll see he does
gravitate towards uh like I just have my
guitars out you know he'll walk up and
start smashing them and stuff so how
would you feel if he you know decided
one day that he wants to pursue a career
music in the country music genre
I'm open to support him whatever he
wants to do if music's it then I'll be
his coach if baseball is it I'll be his
coach if he wants to go do ballet and
I'll find him a coach
there's always a coach out there
whatever he wants to do oh yeah has
fatherhood inspired you when it comes to
the music absolutely uh whole life uh
it's calmed me down in the best of ways
and lit a fire under me at the same time
in the best of ways
I didn't force early on like writing a
song for him but I finally landed a song
that I kind of for him and Delaney it's
called takes after you and can I tell
you how I got the title yes so I was
watching it was like go figure a
Tick-Tock video on my for you page shows
up and it's this guy giving a speech at
a Johnny Cash Memorial Johnny Cash is
there he's like an older guy at the time
he's sitting in the front row to all of
his family and he goes Johnny have a son
and if he doesn't take after Jesus I'd
be all right if he takes after you oh
and so I was like
I gotta write that I feel that so that
was the first first thing I've written
for Ryan has he heard it Ryman yes but
he doesn't know it
did this to it so is that the seal of
approval yeah when he starts moving he
likes it oh my gosh he's almost what two
now yes ma'am oh and it's so special it
like almost serendipitous to that Morgan
has a little guy too and they get to
grow up together as their dad's kind of
been growing up together we have been
growing up together too yes that's right
oh could could we see maybe like a
little band those two a little Duo and
then you know maybe in the future if
Hardy has a child yeah I mean boy
there's hell hell to be had yeah yeah I
could see a little Duo you know I think
Wilder Saint ryman's middle name is
saying Indigo Wilder you know Wilder
Saint we kind of got the name teed up if
they want to do it you know what I would
not be surprised if years from now we're
rolling that little South up next Wilder
saying there you go it's writing itself
the next generation of country music
stars right there in your household I
love it what is that what's next for you
with music because obviously you have
the debut album out now are you working
on your sophomore album or has it been
you know you've been out in the road so
you know I know each artist is different
whether they you know do right on the
road whether they take kind of their
back seat yeah I uh once I put the album
out I kind of took a break from writing
just letting the Music Live and the last
three or four months I've been writing a
ton I went back in the studio and
recorded a bunch of songs and there's
there's a plan for more music coming out
by the end of the year and top of next
year so yeah I'm always going to be
cooking something up
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and also like I feel like a lot of
people don't realize that you are behind
a lot a lot of their favorite hit
country songs in the genre maybe
but I've noticed a there's a lot of like
the the guides that you write with is
there a country female artist that you'd
like to write for next Lainey Wilson
yeah that girl is awesome
unbelievable the I believe the most
nominated CMA artist good for her she
deserves it have YouTube had
conversations about writing together oh
yeah okay yeah I told her a couple years
ago we should cover that Louisiana home
and Mississippi Man hey
[Music]
Mississippi heart but you know it hadn't
happened yet but yeah we'll do it okay
we'll we'll still happen we'll also roll
that side back in and we'll have we'll
have something together Ernest thank you
so much for joining us in the meantime
we're gonna let Ernest play us out with
his latest music video for feet wanna
run girls
[Music]
and I can't seem to live
[Music]
with my feet wanna run
[Music]